[Music]
hey everyone I'm ash Crossan and I am so
excited someone I've been wanting to
talk to you for a very very long time
good
finally we no no watch all my content
when the call came in you have a movie
coming out today
Gerard and Huey yes um tell me what the
movie is about and how did you get
involved well Bernard and Huey is based
on a - cares that were created in a
comic strip
way back Jules Feiffer who is a amazing
playwright and obviously Oscar winner
and he had created these characters in
the Village Voice back then and it was
just basically these two middle-aged men
and they would the panel's would talk
about sex love divorce all the things
aging and they pretty much this is a
screenplay based on those two characters
with me and Dave Koechner plays Hugh you
know play Bernard and they're basically
two men who were great friends and then
they were estranged for 30 years and
it's when Huey's character comes back
into my life and basically you know men
and midlife crisis not behaving very
well and much smarter women hopefully
can make us a move on I think I'm better
men as life goes who would you say I
hate is Kristen where I'm like who is
this for but like who would you say okay
who the hell is this for but who would
you say kind of is the target audience
for well I mean I certainly a fortune we
probably all know men like this who are
stumbling their way trying to to outrun
time but I think you know it's a
wonderful you know Sasha Alexander and
Bellamy young from scandal it's got a
great cast which I hopefully will
attract a wide range of audience yeah
one thing I always like seeing kind of a
younger version of people what is it
like when you because you have like this
younger version that was terrifying yeah
what is that like one because they found
was specifically for me I mean it's
pretty scary that it could have been me
yes we had these flashbacks obviously to
earlier days and
though those actors came to our real
rehearsal I'm pretty much started
studying you know Dave and and I and so
pretty much when I started watching them
and their scenes I was like I had no
idea of my hands do that you know
they're studying your face and you're
like you're looking in the mirror of
yourself of like okay yeah I got to work
on that you're like you're not doing me
at all at everyone on sets like oh no no
that's you
that's 100% no they did a fantastic job
yeah one of my biggest takeaways that I
didn't know Jim rash very ripped oh yes
thank you no I wrote it down there don't
worry I would get to it you know when
you know in between jobs you work out
some stress I guess you know when you're
single you know whatever half the world
was like what keep going what we spoke
about your writing I'm a huge fan of the
way way back in the descendents and I
was kind of going through your credits
and I was like man I really hope Jim
rash gets back and starts writing
another movie again is there anything in
the works yes I want to do absolutely
you know it's we way way back was
probably 2013 and it's not way back way
way back in this boy and and you're like
oh I got one too in us but no we have
been writing we have a couple of my
writing partner that fax and I you know
it's like we both have acting careers
that also are all be separate from our
mutual career so when he was you know I
was on community and then he started
doing you know married and Ben and Kate
and so it just you know in between those
things we would write but we have come
very close to having our next movie made
and we're hoping to target for next
summer's or as production but you know
it's like a movie it's almost ready you
know to the finish line and then
something falls apart and it's difficult
but but we are writing I can promise you
okay I can you know you can come home
and I'll show I'll prove it yeah sounds
like we don't but we are yeah we'll work
on stuff ya know cuz you you always play
these like super funny characters and
then you write these just I don't know
it's it's almost like I I disconnect
your writing with
characters that you play yeah it makes
sense no it totally makes sense because
I think when we when we got involved
with The Descendants you know NAT and I
met at The Groundlings in Los Angeles
and that's sort of our training and so a
lot of people were being like how we'll
do to sketch guys have the capacity to
be a part of the descendents you know
and writing you can't be funny and no no
it's not possible
they're not allowed they want you in a
certain box but I are you know what we
were learning was character development
and writing for character no matter what
you know whether it's a sketcher or we
were pilot and movies and it really was
about character and understanding them
the way they are and I think weirdly
where we are in our lives will gravitate
more towards you know the drama T of the
world and our writings so it's it's
really just a way to like you you have
fun being like Dean and community and
then go home and type you know some sad
that's okay Saturday night well speaking
of Dean though probably question you've
answered in every single interview ever
will there ever be a community movie I
hope so I know what's keeping it from me
I'm Joel McHale said it was Donald
Glover I think everyone can just say
blame someone else will say Joel but
it's not you know I don't know it I hope
it happens you know maybe we'll all be
80 and 70 and it will be a really
interesting movie
well speaking there is a little bit of a
community reunion this is a bit of a
stretch okay in the Star Wars universe
we've got Donald Glover oh yeah as Lando
and we've got you you're gonna be in
Star Wars resistance what what who said
that I know that 400 wait what what do
you know something about my career that
I don't yes okay well I mean I kind of
guy I got to figure out where this job
is oh god yeah so you're doing that
animated one yes of course that's yes
you'll hear pretty much this yeah come
out of a creature yeah it's really cool
I mean that was one of those things
where they said you can't talk about it
and then I was working Bobby Moynihan
and I are like basically two guys who
basically run the equipment you know
sort of check out area yeah cliques sort
of like Oscar and Felix it's
Lily character named flex I love that
yeah it's pretty cool is that kind of
like a dream come true like are you a
lifelong Star Wars fan or like I mean
yes I mean obviously I grew up on the
original little chunk there but I mean
how could you not
yea be a piece of yeah that's got to be
incredible I don't I like oh well you
know I wish I knew more because you know
obviously we drop in and did that sort
of as a recurring so there's so many
things that happen in between that
really are not privy to right so I can't
wait to see it I saw like at best I saw
you know early animation you know and it
was already amazing this wasn't even the
finished product okay so there is a
running joke of community cameos in in
the Marvel Universe as well yes keep
startling back to community why not yeah
did you ask the Russos kind of what
happened to your character post infinity
war is he okay yes what's going on all
right
hi here's here's what I you know I
pretty much know I have a feeling that
the Russos are like you know what we're
gonna have gems characters save the
world so I'm most most likely Iowa my
guess is no I have not heard from them
we have not shot anything but I have a
pretty I'm pretty sure they're gonna do
a pickup day yeah we find out that I
have powers and I saved the world so
it's all good yeah we thought it was it
was such a pivotal yes it was so cool I
mean believe me it was so cool to be
there and and they've done it a couple
of times with different community
members can't even arrest a moment
that's another Easter Egg yeah as well
they had the whatever you call it that
the moby although it was it was on the
tarmac while you're fighting yeah and
then they also had the blue guy yes well
tell us where we can well Bernard Huey
yes comes out June 8th Friday and it's
on video demand most platforms also
select cities if you're happy to be in
Los Angeles it's at the Santa Monica
Laemmle and a couple other little places
in around New York and some other cities
perfect yeah thanks so much for coming
in welcome thank you
let's for having me
you
[Music]